where you go bro
uh zoo culture gold's gym real gems dude
real gems chris all right all right all
right gold's gym it has gold in the
title of it yeah dude rich uh
yeah no bridge no why don't you go to
diamond gym mars gym yeah dude crisco
say equinox
bank of america jim you idiot yeah dude
[Laughter]
you ever met this guy oh i'm the dumb
one you can't argue there's something
about me you have no idea what you're
saying
[Music]
what kind of shirt is that theo mr
vaughn paige and mr vaughn what's up
boys this is a shirt called hot hoes hit
this is from uh
uh
a line we had over there at theovon
website you full of [ __ ] man that's a
wwe triple h shirt man
nice try nice try sir
dude why don't you juggle my nut son
this is a damn uh
this uh shirt for no
a
couture line we had
nice nice good it goes good with your
yeah i like your hair i like how it's
growing out a little bit on the front
oh thanks man
just dropped down huh just dropped down
it grew too long can't style it up
anymore that should just drop down looks
nice well that's true
yeah i appreciate it man at a certain
point you got to make a choice you know
on your hair mm-hmm
well you can't really make the choice
anymore it's just going to [ __ ] drop
the [ __ ] down you can't you style it up
that would be crazy it's real long you
can go longer
i don't even think it's that long right
now honestly what well it is it's long
up the back dude and also sometimes life
decides how your hair is going to go
like like make a poster of that well
like god is brian callum's barber you
know what i'm saying right like he tells
him where how he's going to go he has no
options right you guys have options we
know i have options yeah you guys you
guys have options you don't honestly
theo
i don't think brendan has options with
my hair yeah
i think if you grew it out it would be
worse than a guy going bald
how much hair does he have right now bro
i gotta i have so much more here than
everybody in this room i get to worry
about my my hair running into my
eyebrows i understand but i'm like he
looks like a damn
he looks like a lesbian stewardess on an
ice cream truck is what he looks like
without a mask though [ __ ] here we go
i'm saying that if you grew it out you'd
look terrible no i'd look [ __ ] sweet
dude you'd look sexy i look like jared
leto
i don't want to talk about geraldo
number one period and also so early but
theo knows him now i have a direct path
to him theo tell us about that chris
what are you doing out in the daytime i
think is what a lot of point you know
what night walker okay but guess what
and i know the [ __ ] elephant in the
room yeah i got color look at my face
uh
no
no no no i don't know how theo's
theo's camera is but there's no color
look no
no you look like boo radley at a jack
harlow show i feel like i don't think
sounds like a good time yeah i love jack
arlo
you d you don't know anything about him
brandon and you don't have any color you
think just because you're into white
rappers you know everything we fly i'm
not into white rappers
up in the sky come on dog i'm the
biggest dark harlow fan jar carlo i'm
the biggest giancarlo fan
an italian rapper
yeah
listen oh yeah prosciutto prosciutto
prosciutto oh i like that
okay so everyone stop what they're doing
right now
everyone even listening stop what
they're doing right now go watch gringo
poppy somebody has to say it dude
wow it's out go watch gringo poppy it's
[ __ ] uh brendan's second special
even though his dad thinks it's his
first it's his
it's his second special it's out on
youtube go get them clicks up gringo
poppy is out right now so it's on
youtube it's all over thick boy so uh go
take a look and [ __ ] thumbs it up and
comment you know what i mean keep that
algorithm moving yes sir thank you sir
yeah man congratulations on getting it
out thanks brother i appreciate you guys
man you guys motivate me and give me
support more than you know so i love you
guys well love you back well don't gay
out honestly no honestly well i gotta
get up a little day out a little bit
honestly and that's what by the way i
think that we should do promo stuff like
i'm going to be in phoenix on saturday i
think we should do promo stuff earlier
on dude because people yeah dude don't
you think people well
like
i mean like okay so here's the deal i'm
going to be in phoenix saturday uh
celebrity crystallia.com celebrity
theater two shows go get tickets see
because people stop watching youtube
videos like 20 something minutes in
right that's true dude sometimes i
forget to tell people that i'm doing an
extra show at the wilton on may 7. see
there you go
and i'm coming to georgia in june three
different cities in georgia you probably
sold an extra 20 tickets because we did
that way earlier right now i'll tell you
what's crazy is i dropped a special but
i got a new hour man i'm in charlotte
may 5th through the 7th comedy zone the
boy's still in clubs be cool man no
we're tommy's own charlotte and then i
go to philly at the helium so get you
some
brendan's one year away from doing porn
i think honestly but that's just you
know you know
you know how much that would [ __ ]
actually crush dude if you did porn
unonly fans and [ __ ] you too dude
forget our patreon
we'd be the i heard that bad baby made
like 40 mil 50 mil and then had a
receipt because everyone's like you're
so full of [ __ ] she goes oh oh really
and she goes suck on this then posted
the actual numbers from the only fans
and you look at like holy [ __ ] she made
a 40 million a year 50 million in a year
sir just by showing them titties i don't
know what she does on what does she do
on there oh does she not even show neat
titties i don't know theo would know or
nick that would be my best guess
i don't know theo she's the number one
female bro she's one of the top 60 or 70
female wigas in the world so first of
all you got to respect that bro she's
got her game up
honestly
she made this much
money
50 mil gang 50 mil dude she bought just
bought a house in uh [ __ ] boca raton
six million cash daddy
cash
y'all need to get off this [ __ ] this is
a damn child isn't it you don't need to
quit even looking at this child no don't
you it was all over the news yeah this
is new so
do you even get the news out there i
don't know where the [ __ ] you're at
number 10 you're in nashville who's
buying that look at your set dude you
could be anywhere right now where you at
ukraine theo bro that's a green screen
and it's not even a good green screen
it's just a curtain dude they're full of
nobody dude you're on that you're you're
on vacation in the bahamas huh yeah oh
yeah guess what do this math son
one
wow wait so theo you i honestly think
that three of us if we had a [ __ ]
only fans of one of who do you think
would be the best only fans who do you
think would make the most out of only
fans
the three of us probably theo's ass
though i don't know wrong it depends
what you were doing hands
i think theo has the
could i think theo could
i think
i don't know i don't think i would do it
man yeah well but if i did this would
yeah
i could see y'all one of y'all doing it
easily you guys will do anything no no
no yeah i don't think i no i would do
only fans but i wouldn't show [ __ ] my
dad
and if you'll do it then brendan will
definitely
and then here we are
god theo would be so like i don't know
man if i'm gonna post i don't know this
and that you know i can't fancy yeah one
of the only fans dude i the last thing i
want to keep to myself is my frickin
nuts and b-hole you idiots
that should be sorry my bad no dude thea
would be like hey he'd call you and
you'd be like what's up he'd be like
y'all you show your abs on uh only fans
or what i'm like he's gonna overthink
yeah everything yeah you show your abs
yeah i don't know man i know a lot of
guys throw their abs and stuff and you
have a conversation about showing abs
for 20 minutes and then he wouldn't do
it
yeah you guys are obviously a couple of
freaking local [ __ ] hunters bubby and i'm
not all right
you guys put out there
so uh i think brenda would probably have
the number one only fans though if he
was showing skin if you're showing skin
the best but kind of i don't have a
thrill i'm not i'm not even trying to be
shitty
come on you got a thick bottom yeah dude
come on boston get boston in a little
thong diaper and put his little ass off
all right
all right dude three dude he's two yeah
is he yeah
though but one of the number one things
on youporn is uh mommy porn so i think
phil and his mom would crush it on only
things wow i'm just spitballing ideas
here nobody's listening
yeah yeah true what about you if you and
your brother teamed up dude and teamed
up in what way dude we're called the
dalias the julia what like only fans and
you guys are in songs and like just
wrestling i don't know no i don't want
to wrestle my brother in thongs dude how
weird would that be bro what what if i
could guarantee three mil
guys we have one black dude who listens
to the show he's trying to send in a
video right now
right we have one black friend that's a
fair point how do we split the three
mill okay let's do that let's do the the
dude here we go 80 20 you hey guys
what's up it's deshawn from uh dayton
ohio
i'm just tired of seeing all the white
boys post so you feel there we go baby
thank you thank you for you guys uh
driving a car without any catalytic
converters
you know i've seen you guys talking
about it and i want to know what you
guys think
is that the batmobile
[Music]
good good
that thing sounds lit
my buddy mark got his catalytic
converter stolen in l.a and his prius
sounds like a goddamn thunderbird now
that yeah so it's louder when you get
the catalytic converter yeah a lot of
people do it on purpose oh really oh
it's called pipes daddy
all right but
you said stoling instead of stolen
stolen stolen okay i'm just saying
oh you're in english
oh oh are you missing from overland high
school theo oh hi dude oh hi miss decker
theo said stolen
i said stolen
all right dude i now i've bonded
okay what i'm saying is this bro
yes you if you ain't got that catalytic
converter you're running that cancer gun
baby you're shooting basically this
straight engine smoke right out into the
world yeah sucka
al gore you feel me gretchen how about
this prius sounds like a goddamn dodge
ram
so people do it on purpose yeah so it
sounds yeah loud as [ __ ] now you're not
gonna pass your smog tests or missions
but you sound cool for a little bit do
you have caliber and a lot of time yeah
yeah yeah it's civil war reenactments a
lot of times they would uh have a couple
of them off to the side and people would
floor them every now and then during the
big gun fights as well
sounds funny in fact that says because i
had cars back then but he uh yeah
it's so loud
it's insanely loud people do it on
purpose and but also it's a real problem
in l.a people are stealing catalytic
conversions yeah yeah yeah stealing to
what sell them for other cars i don't
know what they do with them i don't know
the wrong amount probably i feel like
chin might have went down that dark road
chain you ever steal on a cadillac
converter no but i did take my catalytic
convert off when i used to street race
wow dude i knew it yeah you used to
street race yeah oh you don't know
chin's past life dude yeah he did bro he
wasn't like have you seen him i wasn't
in the game
so you like fast and furious you like to
do you because we started building our
cars way before that movie came out
yeah yeah i understand that but like you
were into that movie though
just because they had import cars not
like you know domestic guys
myspace he had the quote that said i
live my life
wow huge huge vin diesel fan yeah chin's
the biggest vin diesel fan seen all the
movies seen that one where he's [ __ ]
tokyo with little bow wow that's that's
jin's favorite movie no the pacifier
where he's the nanny i didn't watch that
i did no
i'm not i'm okay i was a huge spring
roll
you caught me dude you're good
let's take a little break from the
program and while you're taking a break
go watch my new special the gringo poppy
on sick boy youtube it's out right now
enjoy friends i worked hard 30 minutes
of lighting up my latina family go watch
it with a bag of flaming hot doritos but
listen if you're listening to this show
right now the king the sting in the wing
all right felicia's podcast our goal is
to create the best overall show
experience possible we would appreciate
feedback about the show and the chance
to learn a bit more about you the
listener our fans we love you guys we
are asking you guys to complete a short
survey that takes less than five minutes
please go to castmedia.com
survey click on the podcast album art to
take a short anonymous survey to help
support this show as a reward
survey participants will be entered to
win a hundred dollar amazon gift
certificate
again that's castmedia.com survey and
click on the podcast album art for the
quick survey to help the show thanks for
getting listening everybody
you gotta celebrate life's special
moments all right and mother's day is a
big deal you guys love your mom show her
with a gift
mark mother's days with something
enduring classic diamond stud earrings
all right elegant tennis braces i told
you this all right
so go to blue now give the gift that
keeps on giving to your mom because
mother's day is a big deal i don't care
how good your mom or how good she wasn't
she deserves a nice piece of jewelry
from bluenile.com and the cats listeners
and viewers you get 50 bucks off when
you spend 500. this is a podcast
exclusive only good through mother's day
use code kats that's code kats plus
every order is insured ships free
arrives in discreet little package all
right so it won't give away your mom's
not gonna know what's in the box all
right what's in the box what's in the
box
shop stress free and find out
where your forever pieces at i'll tell
you right now it's bluenow.com go to it
right now bluenow.com promo code kats
all right before we get back to the
program we got another read for you
the nba playoffs is here you're not been
on the brooklyn nets anymore because
they got swept thanks ben simmons lost
all my money dude you could have showed
up for one freaking game whatever
the celtics are still rolling you can
make money if you're a celtics fan or
just a fan of the nba playoffs in
general with draftkings the official
sports betting partner of the nba this
week new customers can bet five dollars
on any team to win and get 150 dollars
in free bets instantly you win no matter
what you got nothing to lose all
draftking sportsbook customers can also
bet on nba hoops with the same game
parlays combine multiple bets from the
same game for a bigger payout the more
legs you add the more money you win plus
each day of the first round you get a
risk-free bet up to ten dollars if the
same game parlay doesn't hit download
the draftking sportsbook app right now
use promo code k-a-t-s bet five dollars
on any nba team to win
their game during the first round of
playoffs and get one hundred and fifty
dollars in free bets instantly that's
promo code kats at draftking sportsbook
an official sports brand partner of the
nba minimum age eligibility restriction
supply see show notes for details
also vin diesel's instagram is fantastic
the best he's he's out of he's the best
i saw all pretty much all the movies oh
yeah you're the biggest fan we called it
wow dude
we exposed chicken exposed it's true i
did i never knew really who was a vin
diesel fan in america i thought vin
diesel fans were mostly like european
um yeah like i didn't know there were
actual american vin diesel fans well 78
million followers doing something
no no a lot of prison man too he is
prison prison man love him
that's a good point he's got a great
unaware
uh instagram yes he does what's up with
unaware
people on [ __ ] social media
celebrities i don't get it nothing
better vin diesel
and who else is like that unaware just
unaware how they're being
i mean look at it imagine taking that
picture let me take a nail look at what
he's doing and his wife's like let me
get this shot babe theo you see this his
wife
um
can you see him taking this
can you see him doing the colin
kaepernick on the [ __ ] beach i can
see this dude yeah with a black heart is
the caption
like look you know look like well you
can't see this but his pants are pulled
down a little bit and he's softly
thumbing his [ __ ] dick
[Laughter]
1.6 million likes
that's crazy that's how he uh has a
that's how he jerks off at the beach
right there with the low tide he's doing
better than us man his videos are so
great he's on like a dude
he's on a [ __ ]
private jet he's like i'm just so
grateful for everybody
that's a damn quad bro
that's a rental that's a rental yeah
no he could buy that
oh yeah he's almost but he didn't that
day
yeah so he rented that [ __ ]
um all right desean baby deshawn thank
you to sean for being black and for
liking us
first of all no particular order
and i want to be honest
today we're like the new abercrombie
dude we used to be all white now we got
to mix it up used to be cool to be white
it's not cool to be white anymore no
hell no this guy's got a cover uh he
wants to play for us the video is a
minute 20 so let me know and you want me
to hit okay hit the gong okay
what's up boys theo brandon chris
hopefully eric's there too chin and nick
so yeah you guys are super influential
on me first with the breathe right
strips a couple weeks ago
he had a video already he mentioned
morgan whalen and i've been into him
he's [ __ ] good
check out this little cover i did see
what you guys think
[Music]
okay let's pull
feels lucky he's not in studio i'll grab
your little ass right now dog cozy up
[ __ ] honestly if you try to touch me
i'll punch you you creep
he uh he just started listening to
morgan i'm sorry wayland
okay i said it wrong oh i should never
look at brendan to see how to pronounce
something well i was just saying how he
said okay okay so you guys sounded cool
but yeah so uh that's he just started
listening to him and now he can do that
yeah dude and clearly he's on the set of
jurassic park yeah that's crazy bro play
this song
that's jurassic park oh yeah
and then let me just because i can't
sing i'll be the t-rex
too loud way too loud in my earphones
how do i make them go down
number one okay thank you very much well
number two and i am aren't i he's number
two in our hearts two you're trying to
could you oh i turned two it's hard to
tell on my line on my on my uh
on my uh
audio here if it's good if it was good
or if it was good or not
it was he was good he kind of nailed it
too
yeah he was decent music like a
[ __ ] that's what i thought i
thought he was decent i think he's a
nice guy i'm glad he's got the breathe
right strips and his brain you know he's
getting more air into his brain bro i
need that
wow dude i need them so does it do you
have some you know what fix is i don't
get them i know but i noticed theo you
doing the thing where you just pull the
side of your face a little bit
yeah right that and i noticed you're
doing that and i did that the other day
and boy does it help oh my gosh i think
i think theo and brendan i think what we
should do is
i think no i think breathe right strips
are not the way to go now just hear me
out dude they do work but man if we you
know how like sunglasses have that
[ __ ] strip that you can like put
around so they don't fall dude if you
had breathe right strips think about
coming from the back
like and pulling your cheeks out to the
side it's called a facelift do you
understand what i'm saying like a
facelift breathe right strip dude that
would be the move like king this thing
in the wing breathe right face straps
yeah like flip we can barely sell the
mugs that we have dude we have
do we have them we could barely sell the
we still we can't do i don't think we
can oh we got some fire
droppings
i guess we could do something maybe if
you had a spec where would it hook
around the back of your head i don't
know that's the thing but that's but
what we could do is we could get funding
from we could go to shark tank dude
that's so something a shark tank would
be like sharks are you tired of using
breathe right strips and you peel them
off your nose you don't even have to
peel [ __ ] off this yeah you sleep they
just come from the back it could be
magnetic or some [ __ ]
if we could just cut our face open we
could breathe so much better i think i
know but then you got to do surgery are
you going to do the surgery theo oh yeah
he's doing it
uh no i've already i don't know what
they would do i mean the problem is they
went in there one time with this little
jackhammer and uh and it didn't help so
the surgery takes a long time to get it
takes it like it takes a long time to
heal up from too i know it's awful i've
had a nose job i had my nose shattered
and i can't breathe ever since i had um
i had to read or read
i went to a guy that said uh he was
gonna do it he's like you you have like
one of your passageways are just totally
[ __ ] up and he was going to fix it and
i never went back now did you go all
right blender can't take a little bit
off the top no dude i would never get a
nose job dude i would never get a nose
job
two for one you and theo
bell pepper yeah but theo's nose fits
his face
does it we would merge noses maybe if we
had a merged nose
i think my nose is
big but i mean nobody's gonna invite a
cocaine party here yeah we all get not
sniff it all up
part of my nose has just is just cocaine
inside of it
well still what do you think what do you
think you are out of 10 theo if kid
rocks at 10 he's a four the kid rock is
not a 10.
on what scale is it handsomeness oh
oh i'm an eight oh no no no no
okay what do you think no no no
all right what are you doing
it's honest thursday okay so what are
you then uh my nose no you period
overall in l.a yeah
in l.a i'm a six no you're better than
that theo's a uh he's fishing for
compliments by saying no i'm not i think
i'm a six i'm aware i am i'm so big
theo's a four in la and he's a seven in
nashville okay theo what do you think
about that no
that's unbelievable first of all why you
would ask this man anything to do with
numbers blows my mind
and um
yeah i'm innate anywhere i go guys nice
i like the confidence the personality
now now we're just saying based off just
look not your career not success just
straight up looks yeah not your
personality right right look straight up
yes you're five dude
i'm tall though dude you if you're tall
you're not a five
i'm not [ __ ] ugly dude if you're tall
and and a five you're ugly hey hold on
you think you're handsome no i'm just
saying i'm not a five dude i don't know
but
you think you're handsome all right well
we've already just
there's something about me and it's not
about the it's not the looks it's like
no no no no no sure both of you take
that out of this equation yeah straight
don't put me in this you already called
me a four buddy
i'm above a five bro dude if fashion was
looking for models you think they're
calling
anybody here well they might call you
dude because you look they have a lot of
urban models and so they might call you
fair point what else you got nick hill
thinks anybody who brushes their teeth
can be innate
i agree as long as you brush your teeth
and take care of yourself you can be
innate that's childhood drama dude
here's a guy right here
columbus ohio i'm 30 years old i got a
king her sing it for you my girlfriend
is almost 29 years old and her parents
track her location doesn't matter where
she is what it's weird i find it a
little odd i've been with her for over
four years so king interesting should i
kick her to the curb or should i stay
with her
um
eric huge fan goddamn bill you made
workaholics what it is
brandon theo love you guys chris
congratulations has got me through the
darkest times of my day bro love you bro
you're a legend kinger sting it should
your girl have her location tracked at
age 29 bro
gang gang buzz buzz
soar
love that dude that's nice thank you for
saying that and i'm sorry man sorry
about your dark times dude but you got
through them didn't you and there may be
more ahead but just remember you'll get
through those as well i'll guarantee
there's more ahead yeah okay well let's
be positive there may be more ahead i
like to be realistic though but he is
going to jump through them god damn it
dude he's going to get through them all
right yeah have some confidence in the
guy brendan no i i i do i'm just
realistic like the water's getting a
little more choppy down the road you're
going to tell me he's a four right now
no yeah once you've lifted spirits up a
little bub all right he's a nine listen
he is uh
it is very very weird that parents would
have somebody who's 29 share their
location with them but i don't think it
is these days but but for females it's a
little different because they get
abducted and [ __ ] you know so i
understand that but the question he's
asking is should he kick her to the curb
because of it and the answer for that is
no but you should definitely have a
[ __ ] conversation definitely have a
conversation but i can understand 29
female if she's going to mexico pretty
often they're kidnapping left and right
and then also if they're looking at your
heart rate and it's 1am and your heart
rate's through the roof you ain't doing
freaking you know the peloton you're
sucking dude you feel me so we don't
want the parents to look at the heart
rate yeah dude yeah you suck
sweetheart are you sucking dick
the parents yeah they don't want that so
i kind of understand that heart rate yes
or you could be eating a bag of those
takis too you don't know what people are
doing brendan but you got to check in at
that point
but i'm saying somebody could be dabbing
up a bag of takis that they got
somewhere at a late night station or
something they don't have to be doing
oral that's a fair point too
i mean out of the three of us who would
get more likely to be kidnapped probably
theo right because you know yes like you
had a van theo
his backside and then also like man is
there rugs in there and then [ __ ]
he's gone and then he'd call us and he'd
be like when y'all y'all guys ever get
kidnapped what do you do
[Laughter]
love you bro yeah but then you [ __ ]
yeah but then you guys would go get
kidnapped to be just like me so
anybody want us
here's what i say you you i think as a
parent you have every right to track
your child as long as you want to track
them my buddy got a b.j
a little bit of aural back in the day
from a girl who wore a uh her parents
had a dang doll one of those
dog tracing necklaces on her oh and uh
and look people do what they do to take
care of their child if you have already
lost one child you might want to double
down on the second one and get them
collared up or get a um
you know even get a special back brace
that may have an alert pod on it
people do all type of stuff to take care
of their child especially if it's a
female females get abducted all the time
look that up please chen
no we pretty much know that that's true
but you can also put the apple tag in
uranus
oh that's another good point you can get
the the fake one from amazon i think
it's like six bucks oh really yeah and
just go through if the [ __ ] swallows
it you just double down uh shove a stack
of them i need to get a bunch of apple
pie
my ocd's crazy dude i would want to get
a bunch of apple things and just put
them everywhere like i have i have them
all on my keys do you have them no you
don't lose your keys bro
no because i'm you know why [ __ ] i'm
39 you you you don't lose your keys you
go where is it never oh come on bro but
i did the other deal
the other day i forgot where i put my
keys and was like well
ct here we go see so now you need to get
your apple tags
you got apple text theo absolutely not
no
no i don't have that i put my keys on a
table or a it's not a full table it's a
semi table basically a quarter like an
eighth of a table
i put my keys on there sometimes i don't
put them on there and that's when it
gets harrowing for me i don't like
losing my keys no nothing um but i've
also you can get into my truck without
any keys and you can even start oh you
got the numbers thing
wow look at it no i used a wrench on it
or a
screwdriver because i got so tired of
not having my keys in wow wow wow nick
you're really mixing up today i see what
you're doing what'd you watch that doc
white hot i think it's a baby we got
[ __ ] chameleon air here
what's up brothers
nick chen meat stick cat's toes
uh brandon theo chris eric and his
glasses
nerd nice but um
i'm sitting out here you know in my car
making a video for nick's a little kink
ass to tesla as you can see
uh elon buy on twitter is stinging
that's someone that uses twitter a lot
i'm not mad at it i think he's better
than most people yeah free speech but
he's also a rich guy
and i [ __ ] hate rich guys
shout out to all you gang gang buzz buzz
nice i like that guy he's fun i like
that amen baby look i'm gonna say look
man first of all yes i like elon getting
twitter
uh the place is just a real it's a it's
a pretty alt-left
hole for sure so i'm excited for
hopefully that finds some way to even
out um
and i think it just feels like a like
yeah i guess it is scary though because
he is a rich guy and who knows what some
of his motives are he hasn't come out
with that cyber truck either he's
been saying that for a while so
yeah i'm glad he has it though yeah me
too i'm glad i'm glad he has twitter i'm
glad he has it but also as far as free
speech go it's also you know elon's not
going to be running this thing yeah i
know that's the thing
hey i want free speech don't silence
anybody bring back not only left but
right people like whoever got canceled
for saying misinformation they're back
it's a good thing man but he's not it's
not like he's
gonna be monitoring every [ __ ] day
he's a team dude come on he's too rich
for that yeah making something really
awesome making something really big like
this private is a huge step into like i
mean that it is crazy that
this is the most global
app and it's going to be a private
company owning it that's crazy dude that
is crazy
i i think it's the stuff in the right
drive it before
well yeah but it was a public company
public in their shares and and they were
they were for sure like suppressing and
like uh you know it like you said all
left you know but man uh it's gonna be
[ __ ] wild i i i don't know i don't
[ __ ] do twitter but like it's so
crazy that uh that this is gonna be
happening and i guess it's a good thing
i guess it's a good thing no it is good
yeah you need somebody in the middle
like obviously elon's not far left
he's in the middle so you're gonna get
all the info man you're not going to
silence people who don't agree with your
opinion people can have the actual
debates on there now hopefully it's not
the wild west where he's like anything
goes well yeah but [ __ ] isis is on
there in the cartel and [ __ ] like that
but yeah he's gonna have a team and it's
gonna be ran well like elon he doesn't
[ __ ] miss he's never failed so if he
puts his attention and his team to this
it's gonna be lit dude yeah can we live
isis hopefully ice has been on there ice
has been on there bro not anymore dude
there he got taken down yeah man
no there's some isis still on there
people are saying you think isis is like
[ __ ] yeah elon musk yeah you got it
we're going to get our account
reinstated yes
i think trump's pretty i'm sure they are
yeah yeah and look let them back in i
think it's a royal rumble let everybody
in that [ __ ] dude i don't know isis
[ __ ] trump cindy lauper let everybody
in that bastard dude whoever anybody do
trump frederick's thing i set him
trump roasting isis how lit that's going
to be yeah but trump isn't going to go
back on twitter he's yeah i guarantee he
does not elon has it yeah yeah i bet he
does he there was his app was a
nightmare he's well he said that he's
not going to because he's going to do
his app that i mean that's what he said
i don't know that's like cnn plus
10 days i'm real current and i know that
[ __ ] okay whatever dude what else you
got nick uh this guy's got he starts his
submission off with a song and you want
to listen to the lyrics because it's
about tonto vaughn okay a lot of
beautiful music out there
on an eagle's back to see my son
as long as it's just one eagle and not
too eager
can we be here on the reservation
musicians want to be
comedians can we
just want to be musicians
gang gang buzz buzz
dude that guy's saying good yeah that
was good was it good it's tough to tell
it was good i mean so much sound a win
like
that's the only problem but he was going
but
here's let me just say
just i don't [ __ ] understand that
this i don't understand people doing
something and then wanting to secretly
do something else just do the thing you
want to do well no but sometimes it's
dude but sometimes that's one
but you you did take singing lessons you
know and you sing all the time when i
was figuring it out i'm a comedian bro
i'm not going out and you're doing a
rapper though no but i'm not though it's
all comedic yeah but pick elaine though
it's comedic i'm not going out and doing
shows i'm not going out and being like
you know what i mean
and actually singing i do comedy that's
what i do because that's what i want to
do but i'm assuming when he says like
singers want to be comedians like who is
he referring to
yeah who else is there you must be
talking to ti
um no there's been some other ones there
has been some other ones maybe he's
throwing shade at the new thick boy
album that drops on thursday featuring
today mike stud burt kreischer crystalia
griffin chris is chrisley going to be in
phoenix on
saturday i think so
that's crazy and he's friends with theo
who is got the second show at the will
turn this year yeah dude and then then
theo is also best friends with the guy
who just dropped this special on youtube
30 minutes lighting up my latin family
so that's fun
a lot of activity going on out there
guys on the interweb yeah oh yeah i'll
say this what's this guy's problem
i can't understand musicians wanting to
be comedians
well it's interesting because i think
musicians get kind of lucky because they
get that part in their performance in
between songs where if they want to try
material yeah or try something new or
navel that they can you know we don't
get that part where i could break out a
little uh
you know a little harp or something and
do something i guess unless i have that
skill set but people aren't going to
hang on for a long time to listen to me
practice a tune yeah then you're a hack
though if you're doing that you know
what i mean it depends josh wolfe does
it does it pretty well he brings guitar
on stage what i'm saying i love josh
wolfe but comedians look down on that if
they're all for sure yeah so yeah yeah
you know what i mean chris
go ahead phil who does it mark eddie
does it
you know some people have done is i
don't know is is it a hacky thing to
have a i don't it depends how good you
are at and it also if you're selling
tickets because you're playing the [ __ ]
yeah flute halfway through your act i
don't give a [ __ ] well look look bo
burnham i mean that dude a guy he's a
genius he's a monster so yeah he's super
creative yeah but is he just a comedian
that's an interesting question i would i
think beau is more than a comedian which
is a good thing he's a great actor too
nick is good
i think nick just does last time i saw
him i don't think he had his guitar yeah
i think it's just musical at that point
it's just a different version i mean
there's so many versions of it you know
some people do wheelchair comedy people
do musical comedy people do
um you know there's a guy that uh
was in a fire something he does you know
i'm not fire comedy but you know people
do all type of different comedy
aloe vera comedy my boy went to go see
jay cole and he did 30 minutes of new
material and just bombed and it was like
wait what do you mean new material new
songs no like trying to do stand-up
halfway through the [ __ ] joke
j cole
what
derek poston went and was like yeah he's
like trying these jokes it ate [ __ ] what
and then he was like hit the beat and
just that was his out he's like oh this
is going terrible oh whoa went to the
doctor yeah bro maybe he's just [ __ ]
maybe he's just bored yeah maybe he's
like [ __ ] this dude i'm gonna mix it up
i'm sick of singing the same goddamn
songs yeah no i'll never you'll never
see me seriously singing or anything
like that ever i mean ever you sing on
every king sting but i hear you but not
seriously though
i know i'm a little yeah
you did a whole album chank smith which
also
cover your ears chin i'll say the title
again all right it's uh it's a joke but
i understand dude if people take it real
then they take it real dude if it gets
you through hard times it gets you
through hard times that's all i'm saying
but you float pretty hard on the thick
boy album making fun of king this thing
in the wing [ __ ] after dark
yeah well i mean hey dude if you want to
take it seriously but it's a joke
let's see what's up with the nanny from
servant
hey king the singing wing
my name is grace i'm an er nurse from
midland michigan
and i got a debate club for you guys so
my husband and i have been watching you
guys forever you know especially chris
since
uh
i don't know since we were in high
school no offense guys 23 years old my
husband and i have been together since
we were
in high school
wow and we've been married for the past
two years
and it's like our parents are constantly
asking us when you're going to have kids
so
one your opinion on that i know chris
has a beautiful baby boy and [ __ ] yeah
you have kids theo you'd be a great dad
one day
um so yeah waiting to have kids should
you wait and spend more time with your
partner get to know each other more um
vacation together stuff like that or
jump into having kids so it sounds like
your thoughts on that i've known your
man since you're saying
sore
cute yeah i mean dude you know like is
i mean there's no rush if you want to do
it do it but here's the 23
bro where did she live though you know
what i mean in la that's [ __ ] young
as [ __ ] but if she oh it's young even if
you're in brazil
i mean 23 dude girl don't do it at 20 23
is only 23 no matter where you are yep
you know i know but i'm saying in l.a
people be like oh you got married and
you're 50 that's young you know what i
mean yeah but kids are like such yeah
like those people are creeps probably
okay but it's like such a responsibility
like i'm glad i had kids later in life
so i was like i am too yeah i am too
because it's chris this lady does not
need any kids this lady does not need
any kids right now her husband should go
to places yosemite
um
everywhere maine go somewhere with your
family ladies have a good time i think
you don't jump right into it you could
just kill 25
26 she has a husband but they don't have
no children that's not a family
well the [ __ ] i do not have a family yet
she wants to go with her so she you go
with your parents go somewhere with your
family as your parents number
this is what i think about this video
i
the problem is
shut the [ __ ] up everyone else trying to
[ __ ] tell her are you going to have
kids well no period it's so annoying
she's asking yeah that's what she's
asking no no no no she's getting some
pressure but she's saying people are
pressuring her and asking her that's the
annoying thing you got to set some
boundaries baby
you got to set boundaries dude you've
got to stop boundaries who's he talking
to
yeah who's he clapping to i have an
imaginary church he's clapping but dude
you you have to you can't see it but
nick's clapping
nick nick's got it nick's uh shooting
his shirt around like a helicopter yeah
um dude you think he has a phone finger
she has to say mom dad i'll have kids
when i want to and then go like this
and do a spin move and leave that's what
she has to do she probably lives with
them and they're like all right see you
for dinner [ __ ] yeah true true but then
also when look 23 dude like girl you
gotta start i would wait to at least 28.
yeah five years described get your
career going and then have those little
critters just a lot man
yeah i think you can definitely i would
i'd put that womb away you know for a
bit i'd back that womb off the front
lines back that warm up
oh you're a farm [ __ ]
we'll let [ __ ] out after winter or
something i would at least enjoy the
summer though don't yeah you know you
don't want to be all
ugh you don't want to be out there in
your body just making milk all summer in
the heat and [ __ ] you just yeah
hold off that's a good point hold off
baby making milk squeeze and milk out in
the summer anybody want milk warm milk
clearly this guy that's a thing
this guy's the mascot of coachella huh
wow your wife turns into a damn dairy
section right after she drops that deal
you know
uh yeah this guy is uh is he at
coachella
that's brendan isn't it
what's going on whoever you got in the
studio today king and the sting my name
is sloan i'm from halifax nova scotia
wow i'm currently in theo's daddy's neck
of the woods in nicaragua wow
my question for you guys today is
backpacking what's your thoughts on it
would you rather travel luxury would you
rather backpack and if you guys kind of
go back in time
and like not be famous would you prefer
luxury or would you prefer backpacking
uh
that's my question for you guys today
gang gang buzz buzz
so
say it say it
oh what you gonna do oh oh
shotgun oh the way he did it the way he
did it so smooth
the way he looks
yeah
that [ __ ] jorge mosby doll
here's what i think dude i i i'm not
saying this as definitive
but the larger percent
of people who go backpacking the larger
percent of people who go backpacking
don't know who they are
yeah they're looking forward and then
they're literally
out backpacking
look i need to go they always say these
i gotta go out and find myself bruh
[ __ ] you're right yeah there guess who
backpack no that guy no and who's lost
out of the three of us but i'm saying
theo you could agree to this the larger
percentage of people who backpack don't
know who they are inside now i will say
this if i'm going to backpack with
someone theo's a good partner he's a
good guy to go cherry snacks he has
stories he likes granola bars
you know what i'm saying off dude you
guys here's what happens is there's guys
in the world who don't go backpack who
are afraid to go out there and do
something like that
and then they talk [ __ ] about people
that do it and those
guys are you guys okay you guys have
never backpacked the furthest place you
backpack is to a coffee bean probably
chris [ __ ] yeah dude
brendan needs a backpack to get through
the alphabet
so the truth is that you guys have never
done it dude i think it's legendary dude
i remember falling asleep somewhere wet
the bed it dripped onto a
larger woman who was sleeping under me
in a hostel
yeah that woman about how backpacking is
yeah she's gonna be like it sucks guys
pee on you yeah
that sucks some random dude pissed on me
in the middle of the night yeah and he
wouldn't stop telling me [ __ ] stories
from his childhood and then he pissed
all over yeah he named
all right that lady needs to tighten up
dude i'm just saying man insane stuff
can happen when you go back back and i
think it's a real adventure deal where
did you like there's a difference
between backpacking in the united states
and then doing it in
lane if you're lost you're lost no but
if you're in [ __ ]
mexico going through some random [ __ ]
part
like you look at them yeah he's a cool
story sure
portugal uh
yosemite lisbon
yosemite
uh
everywhere
england
london
uh germany
um you don't know who you are dude
find peace you don't know who you are
you don't know who you are you're
looking for yourself go out there
looking for you dude i go back back into
the coffee bean it's awesome dude i go
to the coffee bean i'm just like hey do
you know where you know where can i find
i'm just asking people [ __ ] yeah i
backpack at the mall okay yeah which way
to the waterfalls yeah yeah um where's
the cinema i think you gotta get out
there and do it and that guy's having a
great time he's got a sweet pad there
yeah he looks closely gonna meet someone
that guy's not rob he was in
yeah that's [ __ ] escobar's grandson
he's asking us about backtracking he's
always drinking a bud light you're not
backpacking for drinking beer
oh cool shane gillis what's he what
what up theo brendan eric chris my name
is keith i'm from long island new york
i've got a debate club for you guys wow
my wife and i recently purchased this
house
it is a fixer-upper and we're planning
on doing
the work ourselves oh my god
home depot or lowe's for your go-to home
improvement needs oh come on now chris i
know home depot and lowe's are the
places poor people go when they can't
afford somebody else to fix their [ __ ]
so this might be for theo brandon and
eric fairpoint gang gang buzz buzz soar
home depot or lowe's i don't even know
honestly if home depot or lowe's is a
poor place or not i've never [ __ ]
been anywhere near those places listen
dude but i'm a real man this one's easy
it's [ __ ] that's shane gillis who's
on keto listen it's [ __ ] home depot
all day home depot is lit you want you
think backpacking's dangerous theo go to
home depot
with illegal immigrants looking for a
job they're jumping in your truck your
car even if you don't invite them
they're down to make a fence for no
[ __ ] reason at a quality price i'll
give them that dude they'll show up as
spider-man go to hulk for your kids
birthday party they're just looking for
a gig dude it's the wild west you can
get dope ass hot dogs wrapped in bacon
they got churros that's true yeah dude
home depot is lit it's a homo depot dude
where a lot of gay dudes are
beating each other with get in get in
they're outside come on in his truck
come on in
we got lumber we have lumber hop in we
have wood they're all just on the fork
they're all on the forklift listening to
abba dude
that's the place we need and how sad is
it that this zielinski guy has time now
to make a video for
this thing bro
this dude needs to [ __ ] get off the
internet and take care of his country
jesus christ
i don't know man i think that like does
look a little bit like him i think that
i like home depot man i don't know i
like home depot they have gay men in
there also they let anybody work there
you could have they had a dude coming to
me with no eyes in there trying to help
me like just unbelievable they employ
all types of people people in a
wheelchair somebody in a fish tank yep
fellaini they'll employ
oh anybody in that
it's the greyhound of [ __ ] department
stores it's so much fun gotta have your
head on swivel though it's basically
like jail la county you gotta have your
head on so you gotta [ __ ] there you can
just pick up a nail gun and use that
[ __ ] in there like it's very uh
avant-garde dude you'll get shanked
because they have they have tools in
them so you don't get i've been to
lowe's once i've been to lowe's a few
times i've been to uh
home depot once what's this guy king
you're stinging it butt chins whoa dude
what's it like this guy puts his face in
the toilet to [ __ ] bro this guy
this guy's chin bro he's gotta [ __ ]
wipe his ass dude he sneezes and wipes
his ass at the same time
he's a giraffe faber man unbelievable
dude
farting out your chin
i don't know who's on the show today but
mainly question for b shobb since you go
to the gym
this is travis from palm beach florida
and i'm at the gym right now so white
and a guy just walked by me with so much
cologne it startled me oh dude so i was
thinking what's worse oh
too much
cologne
or bad bo yeah my preferences
wear a hoodie cover it up thanks guys
gang gang buzz buzz
that boy's doing work on that but yeah
but say sore but yeah i forgot though
you know question for me won't you boys
take a water break right because the gym
right the gym so i'll take it from here
right um so when it comes to clone
definitely not though right
i'd rather have cologne than bo dude b.o
what are you [ __ ] andre orlovsky why
do you smell like that can't wait to
talk
go ahead
go ahead you now you not do you have a
gym membership can't wait to talk do you
have a gym and i do the gym dude i'm
stacked bro i look good okay
my shoulders go crazy i look good yeah
we all look good i look good yeah well
not according to everybody
yeah well i think you guys look cool
brandon said you're a four and that's i
think i personally i'm gonna go in
record i think that's disrespectful i
think you're higher than a four
that's also semi-disrespectful right but
you're welcome for having your back a
little bit right
you can admit that
okay but what i'm saying is
no
and i'm going to have the hot take here
what's the hot take
so your perspective is equinox right
he's gonna be rich
you got equinox well where do you go bro
uh zoo culture gold's gym real gems dude
real gems chris all right all right all
right gold's gym it has gold in the
title of it yeah dude rich uh
yeah no
yeah why don't you go to diamond gym
mars gym yeah dude crisco say equinox
bank of america jim you idiot yeah dude
[Laughter]
what's your hot take so my hot take is
[ __ ] b.o over over cologne all day
dude you're at the gym it's where you're
supposed to have b.o dude [ __ ] i want to
be on the stairmaster whatever the [ __ ]
i don't do that but like if you're on
the stairmaster and you breathe in some
aqua di giorgio you want to die i like
the natural sense of everything i always
wanted i'm very french when it comes to
this about the natural scent of
everything dude you think like i've i've
been around people with boi i'm like you
know what enjoy being you yeah it's
horrible but enjoy being you you're
trying to cover that up with some
[ __ ] you go boss
but i also think you've been around go
ahead yeah you've been around rich b.o
yeah chris you've been around high
dollar bill you're talking about be
somebody raises their hand to get a
waiter and you get a whiff of it
i'm talking about a different real ass
b.o
when you're in [ __ ] guadalajara theo
all right and they're eating beans all
night dude tell them about it
oh i'm talking about the stuff that has
hair mixed in there with the scent you
know what i'm saying i'm talking about
something that you got to blow your nose
after you smell it yup you know i like
it better than [ __ ] cool water
cologne oh you're crazy i think that's
the gym i think you have that beak i
think your beak is real sensitive my
shit's cool man i'll smell yeah maybe
dude but i'll smell that [ __ ] bee all
day long i enjoy it yeah chris kind of
looks like he's always smelling a fart
or he's always trying to smell if
somebody farted i enjoy you the way you
are don't cover that up come on man or
female male or female you don't smell
strong enough b.o because you're not
living the real world 42 i smelled
strong enough bo dude i think i honestly
think it's your nose
but i would smell the bl more then
i know but i think it's just the way
your nose is built like pointy like that
like a despicable me guy yeah you know i
am like that bring him up nick he's if
they do live action broadway despicable
me you got a job i got to gain some
weight though yeah no but you're the
skinny version you got a job and theo
can play a minion okay you guys look
exactly like them
oh well there's chris
oh and both y'all can play my nuts
i don't think those are characters in
that description yeah they
who's this guy with his hat is way too
big right this guy starts this guy's
starting the fire festival right right
there
that's your boy nut johnson
what's up
josh here
i'm in arkansas so i have to keep my
eyes peeled talk slower i think uh bryce
mitchell might jump out of these woods
in any minute yeah boys a gator trying
to choke me out yeah man
here's my uh
king understand it i mean made that
fishing pole fishing oh
gay or not gay
[Laughter]
it's so [ __ ] frustrating sometimes
slow game
i think it's kind of gay
wow this is funny
this guy's great
that's he's doing it i think he's kind
of gay
it's so slow and boring
forever dude
this guy's obviously chris deleon
witness protection
even though he doesn't want to admit it
and i think trying to catch a i i never
done fly fishing and um i believe in it
but
it doesn't look like that man has a lot
of joy and it looks like he's out there
by himself right now yeah i don't think
he has a lot of friends but i also think
fly fishing you got to be 60 or over man
like you you chill in the water knee up
yeah you just sit there hoping a fish is
stupid enough to think that your metal
[ __ ]
weird thing in the water is that actual
[ __ ] flyer where the hell they're
trying to get he's just chilling he
loves it look at me
you're like because fly fishing is
boring yeah yeah dude be like our girl
hannah be like hannah get get [ __ ]
elbow deep in a catch fish's mouth dude
in the mud do that and be hot i mean
even the movie about it is boring and
boring as [ __ ] river runs through it i'd
never watched that i saw it as boring as
[ __ ] yeah it looks so stupid yeah go
bait or bait a gator man maybe paint
your arm up like a cut of ham or a piece
of uh bacon meat yeah chum the water
gator out there yeah man yeah i mean get
out there and be wild it's definitely
see that man do something it's an older
man's gate it's definitely not gay
though
it's not gay you're super super it ain't
gay bro the guy said gay people throwing
that around too often these days yeah i
mean if you're if you're 65 and you're
doing it with another man
i'd be your buddy kind of gay let's say
we're both the three of us are all old
we got nothing to do theo wants a
backpack and i'm like dude why don't we
just fly fish get an airbnb fly fish
all day get a nice six-pack of cold
bears yeah go back to airbnb oil each
other up okay and go on only fans
full circle dude leave me out of it no
dude grumpy old men only fans
yeah that's what i was thinking is that
a lot of older men like to get out there
and do that i think if you got a nice
rod and real yeah get out there and
learn it but i would be while you can be
younger and more active i would do a
more active style of uh poaching or
catching it yeah maybe high knee in the
water even regular yeah and also heavy
on the rod am i right there no sorry
no he's been talking about nuts all
goddamn day i talk about a rod and yeah
it's too much it's a little too much all
right all right we got two more okay
what's up guys vince from forest hill
course your name is vince i have a king
it or sting it for y'all being named
vince designer breed pups
oh look at the dog
this little guy is a golden retriever
dachshund we call him a golden wiener oh
no
designer brings muppets
dogs living in buzzbugs
griffin dog's living in hell because
he's not supposed to be what it is
designer breed pups are not supposed to
be what they are they have all sorts of
medical problems and this dog right now
is like i shouldn't even be this god
didn't create that thing also how long
you guys want to wait before we tell him
that's a regular [ __ ] labrador yeah
and he paid 10 grand for a [ __ ] i
know he got [ __ ] hoodwinked yeah that
thing looks pretty basic cute dog i'll
give you that okay not a high-level dog
you got a regular dog you got [ __ ]
taken for eight g's yep
but here's the thing a lot of young men
uh are buying dogs like this and are
driving i had a friend who drove
probably 170 miles to get a dog wow i
get it though if it's the exact dog you
want listen i'm looking for these hyper
allergenic cats it is a voyage and theo
if you just backpack your ass to [ __ ]
indiana that'd be great and pick up
these cats for me
yeah but if you're you guys in a coffin
bro god's backpack dog i'll put both
your hoes in the car
god's backpack
what else you got nick
oh guys joe look at the guys joe hey
brandon chris theo oh brandon island new
york i got a king at her stinger for you
guys today first just want to say big
fan of the podcast listen to it every
day uh not quite as good as
congratulations but you guys are great
oh well we know he's a liar off the bat
who would the
today is working with family what's your
guys opinion on working with family
currently i am business partners with my
stepfather here in long island uh we've
been operating painting company for the
past five years long island that's not
long island you know really not the most
conducive working relationship we fight
a lot it's really affected our personal
relationship on many levels uh also you
know trickling down into my personal
relationship with my mother yeah um so
you know
what i decided to do was to get uh a new
job at a different company um great
opportunity for me he's at home
everything would be fine it actually
ended up blowing up we're not speaking
now oh no uh we're just you know it's
it's it's actually become worse um our
relationships become worse than it was
when we were working together i started
the new job soon um so my whole opinion
is should i ever have gotten into
business with family in the first place
so
love to hear what you guys have to say
working with family king it or sting it
it'd sting it but also he needs a
reality show but that sounds like your
father-in-law is a complete [ __ ]
well we don't know his side of it but
yeah but yeah we're getting one side
right one side of it but honestly i will
light at the top right no he didn't lie
he was very honest very truthful right
because he said congratulations fair
podcast but we're not so i would say
better than this that's what he said
but also
um
he said
here's the deal i would have given the
advice i would have given him is stop
working with your stepfather if it's
training your relationship that's what
he said and that is what he did and then
it got worse that's what i'm saying the
step the stepfather the [ __ ] right
right father-in-law's a piece of [ __ ]
could be yeah yeah could be no i don't
know
this guy sounds like a good guy but
anyway i agree hashtag good good guy
dude my brother's my tour manager he's
family he's good at it he makes some
mistakes if he wasn't family i would
fire him right four years ago right you
know yeah but he's a brother she give
him some right right you know but i
think that being family first man yeah
well yeah but but also what's dope about
him yeah is what you can do is if your
father-in-law wants to get all fresh
with you you can fight in the backyard
at the barbecue nobody's pressing
charges nobody's going to fire you
either there's that too dude i think
that i think that you have to if you're
going to work with family they have to
be really tight you have got to be
really close so working with a
stepfather is probably the one of the
hardest people to work with but also
working with friends like best like
we're all friends is worse than that and
then when it talks then when it gets
like money and business that [ __ ] sucks
man
which i want to talk to you guys
about that you want to raise yeah well
friends i think if you get to work with
your family that's pretty neat but yeah
i think yeah you got to make sure that
your family uh that y'all are all dialed
in a lot of times where i'm from people
will do snow cone stands together the
whole family will get in there i like
that and uh yeah and things like that i
think people can handle pretty well but
you start getting into some real more
serious businesses yeah
um i think it can get real risque kind
of with family i'd like to know what the
business was before i give my full
opinion but only fantastic there you go
but i agree
yeah only fan maybe it's a home depot
situation dad only fancy yeah yeah wet
wall
but
i need more info but i've seen first 48
way too many times the the the first 48
have to do it solve crimes dude this is
a crime the dad's being mean to him it's
a crime okay right all right it's not a
cold case because i i solved it right
well it'd be cool a lot of cold cases is
happening now but yeah no it's also not
a case
no it's a
case all right okay fair enough okay
salt is that it that's it go watch my
special it's on youtube right now fake
boy the gringo poppy go get you some man
and then the album also drops think boy
and
itunes amazon spotify wherever you
listen to music the full album is there
it is fantastic shout out to little
brows for putting this thing together i
will be in charlotte may 5th through the
7th you too i love you guys thanks for
the support you guys give me so much
freaking motivation and support man i
honestly love you guys i don't tell you
enough so
i love you too man saturday i still
don't drink water half cavity so i might
die any day you're gonna die
so saturday doing uh
phoenix [ __ ] yeah dude i'll be in
phoenix celebrity theater go crystally
doctor how to get tickets and check out
my uh podcast congratulations what's
that guy likes better than king's thing
i'm just thinking as well yes the lion
has an issue
theo will turn dude another show daddy
yeah i'm happy to have a show over there
at the wilton that is on may 7 over
there in los angeles um as well then we
got some shows in albuquerque
uh and that is on
18th
may 18th may 19th in midland texas
lubbock texas on the 20th in dallas on
may 21 we added a show there and then we
got savannah augusta georgia and
columbus georgia and those are on june
uh third
uh second third and fifth and then
montgomery alabama on the sixth or the
fourth and we added some shows in
florida late june hollywood florida fort
myers daytona and lakeland florida theo
doing the big boy tour man uh last thing
i'm looking forward to that man yeah i'm
proud of you brother you're [ __ ]
crushing both of you guys are last thing
on the green o poppy what we're doing is
with the gringo poppy shirt or whether
you're watching the the special if you
post and use the hashtag the gringo
poppy what we're doing is till next
friday whoever is the most creative
whatever special viewing party with your
family friends dogs your stepdad your
shitty father-in-law whatever it is post
it and the most creative five will get a
signed poster from me for the gringo
poppy and you get a signed bottle of
tiger thick whiskey and then that's the
first five the most creative and then
the other hundred we'll just get the
signed poster and we will decide by next
friday i think that's may 6 or some [ __ ]
and and a hundred thousand dollars so
that's great
no problem no no daddy spent all the
money on the special i love you guys man
go watch the special right now on
youtube dick boy the gringo poppy love
you too man all right gang baby you're
good
it's the king and the sting back up in
this thing
they got me working
all night
how many times
[Music]
[Music]
and the sting and the wing